we've seen how to use open telemetry to
instrument our services for both
distributed tracing and custom metrics
but what do we do when tracing shows us
there's a latency issue in a specific
service that information is often in
logs said today we'll go over how to
bring logs and trace this together into
a single view using open telemetry and
cloud trace and logging this is the
stack dr. let's take a look at an
example app written and go it receives a
user request that's some internal
processing that makes a back-end query
before returning in response using open
telemetry oh you can create trace spans
that will capture the timing of each of
those actions if the internal processing
step takes a long time we want to use
logs written by our app to diagnose
further the good news is that it's
possible to automatically create
associations between traces and logs you
just have to write the ID of the trace
and span into the payload of your log
entries and cloud trace and logging will
do the rest
but what do you get those well first
let's review some basics about how
distributed tracing works in open
telemetry you can refer to the official
documentation for more detail we'll link
to that below a trace is essentially the
sum total of information we want to
collect about the user request as it
traverses our distributed system a span
is information about the request and
response of one of the services in our
system spans include span context this
is the information that must be
propagated with every request that
allows the tracing library to
reconstruct the entire trace when all
requests are completed finally go
provides its own context for requests in
distributed systems that contain
information about request propagation
we'll use all of this information to
identify our traces and spans and
connect them to log entries now let's
dive into our code this is the function
we'll use to write our log entries there
are two main parts here in the first
part we extract the information we need
about the trace and the span from the
context note that there are two steps
here we get the span from the request
context then extract its span context
and finally use that to get the trace ID
and span ID in the second part we use
that information to construct our log
entry we write the log payload and add
the trace and span ID information to it
here's what our log entry it looks like
when it's written to cloud logging
notice that it contained information by
the trace and span
finally when we go to trace we can see
that our trace now includes log entries
we can use them to better understand
exactly what's happening if one of the
spans in the trace shows a latency issue
using open telemetry to connect traces
with logs is a great way to improve the
observer ability of our service and make
latency issues much easier to debug
that's it for this episode thank you for
watching and come back soon for more
this is a stack Doctor stay healthy out
there
[Music]